[Music]
hey guys I'm Carlos I live in beautiful
Seattle
usually it's city of the grade but today
city of sunshine I paid 1995 a month
about $2,000 a month for rent here and
I'm gonna show you my beautiful home and
my apartments to show you what you get
for about two grandmas yeah
[Music]
can you all miners Ellis and it welcome
to my house in Austin Texas where we pay
1950 Thurman as you can see I have 26
foot ceilings we actually live in the
basement of my apartment building I
actually saw this building get
constructed so we kind of backed through
all of this before it wasn't even
finished which is kind of cool I have a
blue nose pit bull who loves to dig in
my last apartment he literally dug
through the floor so with our new
apartment we wanted to get laura7
impenetrable oh the magic disease pretty
rowdy I really try to beat a lot of
greenery in here but I feel like
greenery brings happiness to your home
and lime fin yeah I just think it's
amazing so upstairs in the kitchen in
the living room because we don't have
much but we do want a counter and
we're even fit to eat all of our meals
over here pay our TV and our couch this
is where we spend a lot more time just
hanging out we also have a balcony out
on our balcony I cook every night so I
cook breakfast and dinner every day as
you can see I'm also a minimalist I like
a nice clean space our apartment gets us
quartz countertops which is really cool
we do have a dishwasher here this is one
of my favorite things in my whole
kitchen is this deep sink I also like
this extension a little bit
sophistication all right kitchen is
pretty small but we have everything we
need we actually just got a premium oven
and we also have a dishwasher it is
small but all of our appliances are
right where we need them and don't some
have a nice big pantry we can keep all
of your food another reason why I love
my apartment is that it has a loft you
can actually look right down into the
living room you can see the dogs you can
see your guests and then you also have a
nice view of the trail
[Music]
so it's a two bedroom one bedroom one
bathroom house this is the first bedroom
and both bedrooms are on the first floor
pretty small but it's a decent place for
for what you can get here we have the
second bedroom which is technically the
same size as the first bedroom but the
only difference is that this bedroom has
closet doors that open up instead of
slide open and clearly we don't have
much space but we do have extra storage
space else are in the house which is
really great and this is our bathroom
which is a shared bathroom between
myself and my roommate but it is really
spacious we have two sinks which is
great because we can each be in here
getting ready at the same time and not
be in each other's way and then we also
have separate room with the door with
the toilet and shower which is also
great
if one of us is in in the shower getting
ready for the morning and the other can
still be in after using the same sort of
meter this is our downstairs bathroom I
really like the downstairs bathroom we
have set up shower here my husband
actually uses this bathroom to get
dressed in the morning because I don't
you get something like five minutes and
I don't get up like seven so I don't
want him to be waiting yeah so even
though there's limited space in our
house we do have some extra storage
space in the garage it's great for any
extra clothes luggage furniture anything
else that we need
or somewhere and luckily we also have
parking right outside we don't need to
park our cards in the house and another
great thing about our house is that we
have a washer and dryer over here so the
garage doubles as our laundry room and
this is a really great thing that have
because not all apartments confidence
watch in Newark we initially had the
stackables and we lead on my stackables
so our apartment actually upgraded after
a couple complaint so let's pull about
this building Oh as well is that they
have this app there is a guest suite
which is super cool so for $79 a night
you can actually rent this guest suite
that's in our building it's Airbnb suite
but we pay them directly through your
rent so we get free Umar's from the
building Friday Saturday and Sunday so
if you leave from the building you can
actually get you can get complete five
dollars into like a little voucher
that's actually tacked on an uber
account
thanks for checking out my house in
Austin this is what you can get for
nineteen fifty some of the best parts
are having a nice big garage and a
washer and dryer as well as a big
bathroom
[Music]
so one of my favorite things to do is to
come have a drink on our rooftop of our
building actually see the Cascades
mountains on the clear day having a
drink you have a fire you guys could
show your way out Cheers
[Music]
you